en horas del mediodía un nuevo bombardeo
israelí en la franja de gaza causó un
muerto más que se suma a los 15
fallecidos en los ataques aéreos de ayer
entre ellos tres líderes de la chica
islámica Palestina y diez civiles según
el ejército israelí estos ataques
alcanzaron sitios de lanzamientos de
cohetes de las hijas islámica en hanjuis
al sur de la franja Aunque reportes
palestinos señalaron impactos también en
la zona norte si bien las hijas islámica
informó que el último fallecido Era uno
de sus miembros testigos afirman que era
un campesino que estaba trabajando en un
campo de maíz por esto otras más de 24
horas desde el inicio de la ofensiva
israelí en casa y de una redada que dejó
otros dos palestinos armados muertos en
el norte de Jordania llegó la primera
respuesta de las milicias palestinas que
lanzaron varios cohetes hacia
comunidades linderas con gaza haciendo
sonar las sirenas en ciudades como serot
y esquelón Y es que desde ayer Israel se
había dicho listo para un conflicto de
múltiples frentes pero la demora en la
represalia había generado especulaciones
acerca del motivo un Vocero de las hijas
islámica afirmó que fue una decisión
táctica pero también podría deberse a
una necesidad de reagruparse tras la
muerte de los 13 cabecillas sea como
fuere estamos ante otro enfrentamiento
en curso que según Israel podría durar
varios días de cuya dimensión parece
depender en gran medida de si Se
involucra o no el grupo islamista jamás
en este escenario Israel declaró la
emergencia de 40 kilómetros alrededor de
gaza evacuó a 200 personas y cerró los
cruces con la franja lo que siempre es
un agravante era difícil situación de
los calcetines ya que se suspende el
ingreso de productos o combustible y
ayuda humanitaria así como la salida de
pacientes que se atienden en hospitales
de Jordania o Israel